pour être honnête avec vous, la
planification d'un MBA ne me manque pas et la carrière ne me manque pas,
c'était 20 belles années, c'est très
chanceux de jouer aussi longtemps et mais
maintenant, vous savez, regardez-le à travers ma
fille, ma fille joue tous les jours.  donc
j'aime la regarder se développer, mais c'est à peu
près ça
s'améliorer chaque jour semble
cliché si vous y pensez vraiment comme la
forme la plus vraie et c'est je pense
que c'est la clé de s'améliorer chaque jour
je ne peux pas vous aider
quand j'ai grandi je je  est allé dans une
école italienne ou à l'âge de six ans, donc je pense qu'il est
important que les enfants apprennent plus
que le monde qui les entoure
[Musique]
quand chaque enseignant comment êtes-vous dur comment
avoir la peau épaisse
il n'y a pas un seul terrain de jeu ici
où les gens jouent juste au basket et
ne parlent pas de détritus
c'est inexistant c'est inexistant
alors ouais ma famille n'était qu'un tas de
bavards dans chaque parc je suis allé dans un
tas de détritus parler aux professeurs tu
dois avoir la peau épaisse
[  Musique]
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique] la
manière erratique en ce moment représente l'avenir,
nous devons devenir du vin,
c'est un grand honneur pour nous, vous représentez
notre pays pour venir ici et essayer de
ramener la médaille d'or car elle  est pour
tous les athlètes américains, nous voulons juste essayer de
rendre un pays fier et représenté de la
meilleure façon possible
[Musique]
à Lower Merion High School vous vouliez
être grand vous recherchez la grandeur
mais auriez-vous pu voir la carrière que
vous  Si vous aviez pu l'imaginer à
ce moment-là, je joue dans 20 ans n'était
même pas une pensée pour moi en termes de combien
de temps je jouerais tout ce genre de
suppositions comme 1314 ans, j'avais tendance à
être la moyenne, vous savez, et puis le
les années n'arrêtaient pas de
s'accumuler et donc non je n'aurais jamais imaginé jouer
autant d'années
championnats que vous connaissez et travaillant
très dur pour réaliser ce rêve,
mais ensuite, j'aime que quelque chose comme
ça sorte apparemment du champ gauche,
vous savez, comme j'ai entendu beaucoup de gens me
dire quand j'ai commencé à écrire et ils
me demandaient ce que tu es  tu vas faire quand
tu prendras ta retraite et je dirais bien je veux être
écrivain je veux être conteur et
j'ai beaucoup de ouais c'est mignon c'est
mignon
tu seras déprimé quand ta carrière sera
terminée et que tu reviendras  jouer,
tu sais, j'ai beaucoup compris ça et donc être
ici en ce moment et ils ont comme un
sentiment de validation, c'est mec c'est
fou mec c'est fou
[Musique]